[Music]
in this video i'll be showing you
how to create an experience management
data warehouse
by transforming and centralizing your
survey responses
my name is leah jarrett and i'm a
developer advocate from google cloud
surveys are a powerful tool for all
different businesses
survey platforms allow organizations to
easily collect large amounts of data
around customer satisfaction employee
happiness
brand awareness and more however
surveys are often used once to solve a
specific problem
and then the data is forgotten about
additionally the shape of the data can
be pretty difficult to work with using
standard tools
like sql or business intelligence
platforms
here i'll show you how to use cloud data
prep by trifacta
to transform and load survey responses
from google forms
into bigquery where you can join them
onto additional data sets
and perform deeper analysis using tools
like looker or data studio
let's imagine that i'm performing market
research for my data analytics company
i sent out a google form survey that
asks respondents questions about their
analytics knowledge
google forms will automatically push the
responses into a google sheet
however if i push the sheet directly
into my warehouse
the format would make it difficult to
query
let's take a closer look at this
checkbox grid question
in the google sheet one row is recorded
for each response
where each grid column is its own column
and the selections are
all in one cell separated by a semicolon
now what we really want is for one row
to represent each selection
so that we can easily do things like
count the number of people who selected
each platform project combination
in cloud data prep i've created a flow
that transforms and loads my responses
into bigquery
i've connected the google sheet that
contains my survey responses
and then created a recipe to clean the
column headers
next the data is pushed into four
different recipes one for each question
type which transforms the responses
based on the format
let's take a deeper look at the multiple
choice checkbox grid question
in my recipe i can preview the data at
each step in my transformation process
i've already deleted the columns that i
don't need and now i want to extract
each element from my selection list
first i'm going to extract the
selections into their own
individual columns next
i can combine these columns into a
single array
for each response now that i have
all of my selections in an array what i
need to do
is restructure this data so that each
selection
becomes its own row in the database
and there we have it my data is now
unnested
i can repeat similar transformations for
my other formats
until i have all of my data loaded into
bigquery
in bigquery i can see that trifacta has
pushed those responses
into the four tables representing my
different types of questions
[Music]
i can preview the data and see that it's
now in the format that i would expect it
to make it easier for doing analytics on
and since all this data is centralized
in my warehouse i can easily join it
back onto other data sources
like the accounts table from my crm
in looker i've created my own dashboard
that surfaces
insights about this survey to my team
here i can drill in and see which
respondents correspond to accounts
already in our crm
and directly reach out to the account
owners to let them know
i'm also going to jump down and drill
into my group of users who are data
analysts
that leverage python
i'm going to hop into lookers explorer
environment
where i can easily now send this list of
users to marketo
and target them for an upcoming launch
that we have
and now you know how to create an
experience management data warehouse
where your organization can take direct
action on the insights that they get
from survey responses
thanks for watching